Well, today we do have our guest Menow.
We are going to introduce him again.
Welcome back.
Hello. Hello. How are you? I'm good. How
about you? I've heard you're having a
bit of a recovery from medical stuff.
Yeah, you can you can say that.
uh well circumstances uh are are I mean
better than a week before. So yes, we
won't get into all those details, but
I'm really glad that you're feeling
better. Um I'm standing up a little bit
then you know what's
going on. Yes, we won't have you, you
know, stay planted the whole time.
So perfect. We are having Meadow on of
course to talk about this topic because
he has experience in the music industry
from what I understand. Correct me if
I'm wrong.
Go ahead and tell us about that.
Yeah, I mean uh from a young age uh I
love music. I was uh I was a fan of of
the CCM of Christian music. Um uh I
started listening to uh so I think I was
like like 15 or so that I started
listening to uh Petra. Uh maybe you're
familiar with the band. They're a little
bit older. Uh but uh that's uh I love
the music. I I I the f the first tape
that I I took that from my from my
brother's drawer. And uh that's that's a
whole different story, but uh I copied
it and then my brother was like uh I
hear my my music in somebody else's
room. Uh so that's how it started. Um
and I was 16 years old or so and I was
already um talking with those band
members of Petra by email somehow.
Wow. And uh what I I told this the lead
singer John Slit I told him one one day
I'm gonna organize a concert for you
guys and uh I don't know what why I said
it. Uh it was just like the passion of
course but uh I think it was like almost
nine years later uh I organized the
first concert and he remembered that I
told him that. So that was that was
interesting. Um but yeah the journey uh
itself I mean I I managed artists um I
did bookings tour art tour management
um road management uh concert promotion
so all kinds of uh things in in the
Christian music industry
um and from a young age. So, I started
my first concert was when I was 18 years
old. Mhm. And that was in our own
church. Um, one of another another rock
band called Guardian, lesser known, but
uh they're also in the same realm as
Petra and Striper. I worked with Striper
as well. Um, so quite a quite a few uh
and at some point it was like uh 60% I
was outside of my home country because I
was touring. So, it was quite a quite a
lot of a lot of uh on the road
uh busy. Um but yeah, I've done it for
18 years. Uh quite a quite a while. And
uh there's a reason why I got out u of
course, but yeah, it's it's not the the
glitter and the glamour that people
think it is, right? I'm sure we'll get
to a lot of that. Now I want I mean
let's talk about why this is important
for other Christians to understand. This
topic has been one we've all probably
wondered about like what is really
happening behind Christian music scenes
and so when you speak to that yeah why
should we care?
The question is for me
uh why should we care? Well, uh it's
very important uh one what you're
listening to. Uh uh secondly, uh you
think it's uh there are a couple of
things. One, you think that you're
listening to a Christian artist and uh
sometimes I might think like uh it
doesn't m the the behavior doesn't match
up with what the what the display is on
on stage and you know on on camera.
Yeah. Uh so that's that's one thing. The
second thing uh which is important I
think also in um especially in worship
uh in worship music um that there's so
much apostasy
and
um take Bethl music as an example uh
they have
Bethl believes in a canotic Jesus that's
not the the Jesus of the Bible uh they
believe that he uh um he laid down his
divinity
Well, that's heresy. Um, so that's a
different Jesus. So, uh, and they have
like they're the apostolic reformation,
right? So, they have all kinds of like
revival uh oriented and and they their
definition for certain words uh are
different than what we would understand.
So
if
uh certain words that they use that we
think are are um uh mean one thing uh
mean for them like like for instance uh
healing uh yeah uh God heals but uh we
can demand that right and we cannot call
that from heaven. We cannot say like oh
you're healed. Uh yeah. Amen. Actually,
I like that we're touching on this.
Yeah. Yeah. I I want to speak to that
because it it does bother me because
although we're supposed to be bold and
know our rights before the Lord as his
children, we seriously cannot
demand things of him like I've seen so
many other people of different faiths
and denominations do in moments almost
of rage or entitlement.
I can't get over that. God is not going
to honor that prayer. And most of the
time when I have been present, it does
not happen on their behalf at all
because of their attitude. And when it
does, when it has happened and I've been
present or I've seen videos of it, I
actually know that it was Satan who
granted that prayer and not God because
of the spirit that was within them.
Well, there are two types of healing.
Uh, one is healing by by Christ or by
God. Uh this the second one might be
that an uh the sickness has been
implanted by Satan himself or by the
demons and they just release that that
sickness. Yes. But you know so so you
think that that you're healed uh and
that's that is a real healing but it was
just taking away the affliction that uh
that was caused by demons. That's right.
Just to lure to lure you into a false a
false system. Yes. A false need that
they have a false solution for for you.
Yes, I agree totally. Now, the over the
overlap with with with false healing and
and healing, alternative healing and uh
I mean it's it's it's different, but it
works the same way. Exactly. Now, I want
to clarify for people just because in
the comments someone is asking, "Don't
the Bethl groups lay on graves and call
it grave sucking or something like
that?" That is correct.
Yeah, that's wrong. And that's uh
communicating with the dead. We don't
want that. That's demons you're really
communicating with. So, we don't want to
do that either. And I'm so glad, like I
said, I'm glad you're clarifying what
kind of healing there is. There's the
false healing and then there's God's
healing and how it looks. So, and it is
never guaranteed. Um, and sometimes in
the songs it's very subtle, but
sometimes you hear uh, you know, hear
them sing about healing that you think
like, you know, in a way that they're
claiming it, demanding it, or or just
speaking it out like that they're
healed. And I'm like, yeah, but you you
can sing 10 times that you're healed,
but it's up to God that you're healed,
not Yeah.
you've seen it so many times. Yeah, I
agree. And um I didn't know because it's
always been something that bothered me
personally whenever I'm attending or
seeing Christian music played. Um so I'm
I'm glad I'm not the only one who's
noticed that as well that it's not a
godly attitude
to accompany music.
No. And and and that's the issue. So So
then uh what you're listening to is is
that the real Jesus? And some people
would say, "Yeah, well, uh, I sing about
about the real Jesus, so it doesn't
matter." Well, it does matter because,
uh, the artist, uh, has its intentions,
uh, with the music and with with the the
lyrics and with the music itself. Um,
and secondly, you're you're supporting
uh, moneywise, you're supporting their
ministry. Oh, yeah. So if you play the
music, if you stream the music, if you
sing it in your church, you're you're
you're even if you're against Bethl, you
if if you sing Bethl songs, you endorse
them and basically you you finance their
heresy. Yes.
Maybe it's very harsh to say it that
way, but it is it is truth cannot be
sugarcoated. I'm sorry. Yeah, it's true.
And I I feel strongly about that kind of
music as well not being
promoted with our monetary funds as
people to support it. And um and I would
say there's a third a third thing as
well uh and that is that is the the the
hypnotic
um um seduction. Yes. uh with the music
because the the problem that you also
see with music is that it bypasses your
your brain. So uh even Bethl itself like
I think Bill Bill Johnson would say that
music speaks to the heart you know and
he's fully aware that he's doing that
right and he he's he's preaching heresy
false teaching and the wolf in sheep's
clothing. So it's purposely done. Um in
and there's another group called IHOP
not the pancakes
right but the international house of
prayer uh that's connect all connected
with new apostolic reformation churches
but they have an artist called Misty
Edwards and uh and and some others and
and they are really also very hypnotic
for and and so somebody sent their songs
to a real hypnotist. Yes. uh just to
clarify like hey uh is this hypnotism or
and you know or is this just music and
it came back with a very clear answer
that it was hypnosis. Yeah. Uh hypnotism
uh that you numb the brain and
everything that that that afterwards it
will just absorb the message. So you
will absorb the heresy basically that's
been that's been teached or taught.
Sorry. So well I don't know if you've
heard my story but I was deeply into
music. Music affects me deeply because I
was in the hiphop music world in
college. I was a dancer and it moved me
like I didn't exactly know all the time
a lot of the times what I was doing. it
just would move for me like it would
move my body and then I would realize
later once I was walking off the stage
or so on what I had done I had to ask
someone what did I do and so I can
understand when you're talking about the
rhythm of these songs because they're
definitely that kind of hypn hypnotic
rhythms that actually do and beats that
overtake you that is emotionally driven
and just tap straight into the mind
without your frontal lobe working and
going, "What did they just say?" Like
you're saying, it gets past the message
of the heresies they're preaching to
your mind and just preaches to that
fleshly carnal uh part within you. And
it's the breathy, you know, the breathy
vocals, the ones that just sound like
they're just covering it all up. It's
like flowers. They're just putting
over junk. Yeah. Absolutely. Well, it's
very very interesting that you just said
the the breathy uh songs. I listen to
Christian Perdal. Yeah. Yeah. Uh the
whole series the the whole Siri of of um
uh the dilemma. What was it? The Yes.
The Let's see. Let me try to remember
the something Oh, distraction dilemma.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yes. And he was he
picked somebody from the public and from
the from the crowd and just was singing
if I was saying in their ears like,
"Hello." Yeah. How do you feel when I do
this? you know, but that's what they
what what you're listening to with songs
the whole time. So, it's like it's very
sensual. So, how he explains it is very
interesting. Like, wow, I never thought
about this. But, yeah, you're right. It
is very very sensual. And I always
thought like what do they mean with with
sensual because it's a song, right? But
now he how how he displayed like Yeah.
Eel. It's kind of creepy how how how
that how that feels. Um if you take if
you take away the music, right? If you
take away the whole uh the whole lights
and and all that stuff.
So, but yeah, it's it's
so so hypnosis uh is definitely um uh
um an ingredient that that you see in
music and and the rhythms that you just
mentioned. uh and it has it it has its
roots where is it coming from and you
know it's coming from uh from voodoo and
and from uh African rituals and it has
been brought over. Yes. And that's what
I found out was that, you know, it would
always um be when certain rhythms would
start climaxing. It would get really
quick and then you would really lose
control somehow. Like it just would make
you dip into this unconscious type of
freeing of yourself and everything. And
your body was freed too. But I learned
that's voodoo. Actually, it was a high
level of voodoo that you're practicing
when they usually do a heart sacrifice
when they go in for the heart cuz you
you flail with your rib cage open
um for that music to to cause you to do
that. That's very interesting that you
say that. I I used to uh used to go uh
when I was younger and uh not so uh so
uh uh wise I went
you know
EDM parties and uh hold on just a minute
we have the signals breaking up a little
bit.
You hear me? Yes. Try again. Okay. Okay.
So when I was younger, I went to those
EDM parties. So, uh, dance party, trans
parties, and that's exactly what you
mentioned. Uh, they build up to the
climax and then it's like and then boom
and then that feeling that's like
the explosion, the the whole idea. But
knowing now what what that does, what it
means, it's like, man, that's Yeah.
crazy. Yeah. It's um it was very
enlightening when I finally realized
what was happening to me, what religion
it comes from in the African voodoo or
tribal uh religions, I guess, and how
bad it was and how much I was turning my
back on God when that would when I'd
allow that to happen. And so, um anyway,
Satan, of course, is the king of all
this. He was the choir director. Not
that music is all bad. God made music,
too. He says he sings over us in a
certain verse. And so there is good
music, there is bad music. It's hard to
explain all of that, but we're talking
about certain elements of this. The
beat, the breathiness, the sensualness.
It's almost what you're explaining
actually reminds me, and forgive me for
this, but I am a female as well, and
I've seen other women do this to men,
but it's almost as though you're in the
red light district somewhere and and
there's like a prostitute coming by your
ear and just like, "Hey." you know,
because it does it just kind of whispers
in your ear and you're like, "Oo." Like,
and if you're a woman, too, it's a ma,
you know, it doesn't matter if it's a
man or a woman in some ways for either
one of us cuz music it can be either one
and you're still drawn to it. So, the
first time I heard about this, just so
you know, anybody who's out there who's
viewing, they can go check out Ivorme's
sonic warfare sermon that he did because
he came, he's a pastor. He came out of
the hip-hop world as well. I and Mikey
and even Tilla from School for Profits,
we all very strongly can relate to each
other from where we come from. And so
that's a good uh story. Tilla has his
documentary from his life as well where
he came from as a rap battle artist. And
um I don't know. So someone said ASMR as
well.
What was he was he like hip-hop
mainstream or Christian even?
Mainstream. This was main mainstream. It
was rough.
Okay. Yeah, I haven't seen it. So, yeah,
I will I will later. But, uh, so what
the first band that I managed actually
was a dance act. So, that we had dancers
and singers and all that stuff. So,
yeah, that's uh Wow. Exactly.
in and and it looked all all, you know,
more clean, but it's the same thing that
uh that u uh what was what is the group
um to unlimited and all these other
dance groups would do, right? So, yeah.
Yeah. It's amazing how we and I'm not
trying to pick on anyone. That was my
personal story that I fell into all
these rhythms and the and the beat and
all this stuff and the bad music and
allowed Satan to use me in that way. And
when I finally realized what we're going
to be talking about here is um
I don't know how we think that music and
the way that's being performed and the
people who are performing it actually
are so different than mainstream
artists and music like that is a
fallacy. They are not.
No. And so that's where um we can dive
in. if you can tell us some of the
Christian artists that you have
personally dealt with that were more um
of of this day, I guess.
So, uh I worked with uh I mean uh to
this day I mean Petra still performs but
they're just they're fossils now, right?
Okay.
Uh but uh artist uh I mean I did uh I
did some some work with with Switchoot.
Um I um
um and Phil Wickham was there as well.
Uh I did um work with uh Brian Welch uh
from K. Okay. um when he became a
Christian. Okay. Uh Kevin Max. Uh hot
topic now with Tate. Uh where we will
delve into. Okay. Uh later. Right. So,
um but yeah, uh those those artists and
and some Dutch artists that I've been
working with, of course, where I'm
originally from. I worked with Everlife,
a band from from Nashville, uh Three
Sisters. Uh they were on Disney Records.
Um,
uh, let's see what else. Um, Delirious.
I I did a the first the first big
concert ever concert in in the
Netherlands with them. Um, so yeah, I've
I've seen multiple uh multiple different
type of artists. Um, Striper, of course,
they're still touring even though
they're they're older now as well. But
uh
did their their 25th anniversary tour.
Um and um so yeah I and there more I
don't know all all of them on top of my
head right now but Okay. Well that's
quite a few and I'm you seem like you're
plugged in still to the music world a
little bit because when we talked about
this topic we're going to be tackling
the Michael Tate thing in a moment. you
knew quite a bit about it in fact and
not to share too much but you know
people who had been hurt by his shall we
say sexual misconduct it seems that's
right that's right so um
somehow
in our neighborhood so I mean I'm I'm
living in Nashville right so all the
musicians studio producers
Uh, everybody lives uh lives here in
Nashville. Um, and so one of my
neighbors or in my in my neighborhood uh
through work I got to get into his home
for my work and and I and I had a
conversation with him and I he was a
Christian. He left the same church that
I left when I was uh in a charismatic
movement uh in Nashville.
uh definitely a big N church
and um so we talked about that and then
he we talked about artists that we've
been working with and I told him I was
working with G I've been working with
Kevin Max as an example and then he he
said oh and then he mentioned to me uh
you know like oh yeah that must be
rough. I'm like yeah it's pretty rough.
Uh yeah, all of them are are probably
rough. And and he was like, "Yeah, yeah,
yeah. I I know the the you know, the
stories with Tate." Um and uh I knew
something was off. Uh I mean, there's so
much so much going on behind the scenes.
Um I mean
the but the guy the guy told me like two
of his friends uh and it was before the
whistleblower came out, right? So, but
this this was a year,
maybe a little longer than a year, maybe
a year and a half, I don't know exactly,
but at least a year ago that uh that I
spoke with him and he told me that two
of his friends were um one of them, one
of them with the the I mean, people have
read the stories about the the the
kissing part as an example. That was one
of his friends. Okay. Um, and he's told
me that he told me about uh uh drug
drugging and and and that kind of stuff.
Uh, he told me about the cocaine. He
told me about about the abusive
behavior, but nobody spoke out. Yeah.
Yeah. And it's very interesting to me.
Uh so if you follow the timeline
the the Roy report the the Roy report uh
was the first one that broke the silence
and that was
June 6th I believe if not mistaken and
then all of a sudden out of the blue you
see a statement on on June 10th coming
passing by by Michael Tate right very
reactionary Okay. And he said, well, and
then he said, back in January, I already
stopped and I already went into into um
in into healing process or whatever he's
doing. But I'm like,
yeah, but why didn't you tell any anyone
back then? Why are you coming out right
now? It seems more uh like like a cover
up or uh uh smooth it over and oh, I'm
sorry. and you know I'm caught
um because then and then the and then
you know some some things he didn't even
go into detail or whatever what he did
and um then couple of days later the the
big bomb uh dropped by the Guardian and
Ro report again right so even with worse
stories and all the way back the first
the first story is from 2001
two In the 2000s,
they had a hi hiatus or how you call it?
Hiatus. Hiatus. Hiatus. Sorry. Yeah,
those words. I always struggle with
these words. So, and then in 2001 was
the first. That's the first that's
public right now. Yeah.
I worked with Kevin as well and there
were similar similar things. not the
abusive part to to to kids but the alcoh
al alcohol abuse drugs okay all the same
so um it must have been you know and
that's of course this is guess work but
at the end of the day like if you if you
look back it wouldn't surprise me if
that was all the way in the in the DC
doc era that started yeah I agree um
just for our viewers we have to back up
a little bit I'm I'm sorry so Michael
Tate is the main singer of Newsboys. Um,
he always was pretty photogenic and he's
the only, from what I understand, he's
the only black member of the News Boys.
And so, he's the one we're talking about
and we'll be looking at what happened in
just a few moments. Uh but we also
mentioned terms like NR,
New Apostolic Reformation and him Menow
left a church and was talking to this
man about leaving the same church. Now
can you explain what that movement is
and why it's something you left?
Yeah, that's that's a a massive thing.
Um let's say U so N apostolic
reformation.
Uh it's a movement in
in in a in a nutshell. It's it's it's
not a denomination. You cannot it
doesn't have a headquarters. It's it's a
loosely connected organization with the
same ideals. Um it is dominion driven.
It's kingdom now driven and it is
healing now driven. uh miracles um and
um seven mountain mandate uh basically
taking over the seven mountains of
society, education,
um uh business, church, government, etc.
Okay. And and and interestingly enough,
uh Tate was also involved with the
prayer meetings with Paula White in the
White House, right? And he was also also
involved in God's Not Dead, right? And
that's also very nationalistic and very
very um uh Christian Christian
nationalist. Uh so there's an overlap
with Christian nationalism and and a new
Apostolic Reformation. Uh the new
apostolic reformation. They believe the
the world is going to have a massive
revival um in in a way that that that
everyone, you know, that that heaven uh
um heaven comes to earth uh and that
that we Christianize the world and then
Christ can come back, you know. Oh, here
we go over the kingdom. Okay. Invading
Babylon is another term that they have
with the book uh Bill Johnson as an
example. um they they believe with the
seven mountains that they that they have
to in infiltrate Babylon. Okay. But if
if you have to infiltrate Babylon and
take over Babylon and Christ comes back
uh and he is knocking down Babylon,
right? On which side are
Yes. And that's a good point. I was
going to mention that because if you are
taking over Babylon, you're actually
morphing into Babylon. And so the seven
the the image of the beast. Yeah. That
is morphing into the beast. Because if
you think about dominionism, it's cath
catholicism that that is the earliest
dominionist movement that that was
there. So it's a it's basically taking
over the Protestant movement uh driving
them back to the Catholic Church, right?
inecumenical
I guess centralism of the seven mountain
mandate from the pope by the way because
the seven mountains is the city it's
Rome and then they made it the seven
mountains of different
um different areas of living or not
living I'm sorry but of of actual um
society society like education like you
were saying and religion and so on that
they're dominating to bring this order
into fruition.
So that's what it's moved by. Making the
world Christian uh Christian in air
quotes. Oh, okay. So, so basically what
what what they force Christianity,
right? So they they believe that the
world is going to be Christianized.
Yeah. Um and there are um so-called and
it's funny that the Bible is so clear
that later in the day there will be
false apostles.
Right. And and false prophets. Yeah. And
I mean, did you see an apostle lately? I
mean, did you seen the apo an apostle in
the last 2,000 years after the the last
one died? No. Like with a big with a big
a, right? No. And all of a sudden, now
all of a sudden they they pop on the
scene and and they need to govern the
church. Yeah. No. Really?
Yeah. And it's not going to happen that
way. The Bible doesn't talk about it
that way for all of us to all of a
sudden become Christian before Christ
comes that you can invade Babylon. We
all have a choice to make and
unfortunately a lot of the people will
not be saved. It says only those who are
following the straight and narrow path
will make it. The remnant people. So
whatever they're preaching is not
biblically sound even though they think
they're so Christianized as you said
Christianized
and so it's a huge um lie and deception
for many following and it's put into our
music. This is a mission that they took
on to use the music as a driving force
to do so. That is why we're mentioning
it as part of this. So, without further
ado, I think let's look at um Michael
Tate's confession that he put out
publicly. Let me go to
this. I have to zoom up real quick.
Okay,
I will go ahead and read parts of this.
This was on Instagram, by the way, right
from Michael Tate on June 10th, 2025. It
says, "Recent reports of my reckless and
destructive behavior, including drug and
alcohol abuse and sexual activity, are
sadly largely true. For some two
decades, I used and abused cocaine,
consumed far too much alcohol, and at
times touched men in an unwanted sensual
way. I am ashamed of my life choices and
actions and make no excuses for them. I
will simply call it what God calls it,
sin. I don't blame anyone or anything
but myself. While I might dispute
certain details in the accusations
against me, I do not dispute the
substance of them.
When I abruptly left News Boys in
January, I did so
to get help. I was not healthy
physically or spiritually, and I was
tired of leading a double life. I spent
two weeks at a treatment center in Utah
receiving help that may have saved my
life from ultimate destruction. I have
been clean and sober since, though I
still have lots of hard work ahead of
me. So, I'm going to just leave it
there. Um, I don't want to go over all
of this,
but
I just want to start with that being
understood that he left the news boys.
Um, most people didn't know that, but he
actually left. I think it was under the
kind of like this disguise of him
retiring
and or just leaving for no reason and
then all of a sudden this came out as a
confession of why.
Do you have anything to to add to that
or?
Well, um, so there's a a few things
here. Uh, so what I already mentioned,
the 10th it came out and the sixth, you
know, he was exposed. So it's kind of
like a um, but it's it's a it's it's a
carefully worded confession, right? is
following public allegations of drug
use, alcohol abuse, and unwanted sexual
conduct toward men. But it's fake
admissions. Uh it falls far short of
biblical repentance. Uh and even more
disturbingly,
uh they came only after decades of
silence, right? So from both the artist
and the industry that protected him. Uh
so in my opinion, it's a shallow
confession after years of silence. I I
do understand that. Um, let me go back
to you and I. Let's see if I can.
That's that screen.
That's not quite right. What what what
I'm saying is T they never voluntarily
came forward and uh he's exposed and
only uh then he he spoke up and and
that's kind of like a calculated
fakeness to me. Now I may be harsh and
and and maybe um direct in that way but
but that's I mean that's what I
think. I'm not saying like this is this
is truth, right? But that's how it comes
across to me. And I understand that
because it's um I was reading about
this. I don't have the article to pull
up now, but they were talking about the
band members. Like you're saying, the
industry knew it was happening. How did
they not know behind the scenes that
it's been happening for a very long
time? his mates in the band should
probably have seen a lot of this in
personal conduct and living with him and
they didn't say anything. Let's um let's
consider here that they were hiding his
secret the whole time. His secrets, it's
actually multiple ones. And I'm not
going to I'm not trying to put them
under the bus, but quite honestly, they
perhaps have secrets of them of their
own that they're trying to hide and keep
secret also. So, no one said anything
until now, until he was ready to somehow
put a little bit of the truth out there
for people to hear about. And I'm am I
personally am grateful to hear that he
was willing to do so at all. that does
at least show a repentant heart in some
ways. But you're right, I don't hear
too much of that repentance note in
there fully. But I do hope and pray that
he will have that full repentance from
God and change completely. But that's
all we can do is pray and leave it in
God's hands. But many people, this isn't
the first time that we have seen
Christian artists fall short
of their Christian walk, but many who
are Christian do not expect Christian
musicians
to fall. And that is something I um
think we all this should be a repeated
pattern that we understand. Christian
artists are the same in their humanity
as you and I are. They are human. They
are sinful and we should actually not be
putting anybody on a pedestal like we do
unfortunately with Christian artists or
pastors even I'll be honest in certain
it can happen in any church but you
don't don't put anybody on a pedestal
just do not
because I found that there's always
something not that that's a bad thing
I'm not always looking for the bad in
people but you cannot not find one
person that is holy like God that you
want to be like in all areas. You will
be disappointed when you find out in one
way or another that they they have
failed and you do not want to be like
them in that way.
And so um that's the full story about
it. Um, there is also of course this
understanding and maybe you can speak to
this because you were on the booking end
and you understand the contracts a
little bit more, but I went and looked
it up and Mikey did too. I wish I could
find it. I probably should have done
more research on this. Someone did a a
wonderful video showing
that the Christian artists are all
signed to Capital Records, which is a
mainstream record company that also was
attached to, if I'm being honest,
all of the not specifically to the Diddy
stuff, but they are all kind of under
the same record stuff. Correct. Yeah.
So, so, um, I think it's, uh, I I think
I've seen a video about it. Um, uh, and,
um, yeah, so it's true. the the the the
all the the record labels are the
Christian record labels are owned by the
the Sony's, the the the the
EMIs and and and Universal uh music uh
BMG uh whatever all these big ones that
are mainstream where Beyonce and uh uh
Madonna and whoever are on that's where
you know they have only Christian label
like a they're a Christian label. and
it's run by Christians, but at the end
of the day, uh it's as worldly, you
know, it serves one purpose is making
money. Yeah. Otherwise, you know,
they're in for the business. Uh so if
it's not profitable, then they they
they're they're closing that business.
But the Christian music is very
profitable. Why? Yeah. Because they sell
something. They sell Christianity. Well,
Christianity cannot be sold. That's
right. Uh and and what what what version
of Christianity do they sell? Ear
tickling Christianity
um and false Christianity which sells of
course. Yes. Um, and you see that in in
in videos as well. Like for instance,
Amy Grant in the past, she had uh like
like she was clo clothed like like a in
red rope uh like Satanet Satanist
priestess with on her hands uh she had
pentagrams on her hands uh in the video
and
all kinds of weird stuff that I'm like
Amy Grant. She was like the I know
grandmother of the gospel music. Yeah.
So
um but yeah it's the the the booking
agents same thing. Some of them are
standalone but yeah CA William Morris
and Endeavor they're the big ones. U
they have mainstream artists and
Christian artists and you see an overlap
right you see them also cross over. Yes.
Um, and being at the Grammy Awards and
yes, why? Okay, we will get into that in
just a minute because I have questions
about that too. But I have been told
that actually on Tate's Instagram here.
We'll scroll a little bit further for
everyone. We'll come to pictures of him.
Um,
if I can get to his other pictures here.
He's with a group of people, young
people it looks like. But he has a
picture.
Let me go back. I'm sorry. He has a
picture of himself at Capitol Records.
Bear with me. I will try not to go too
quick so you guys can see all of his
pictures. Also,
I don't want anyone getting sick from
the way I'm trying to move here on the
screen,
but I hope I can find that.
Oh, here it is. So,
um
the question is, how do I make this full
screen?
Oops.
That was not right. Okay, nobody look.
I'm going to scroll really fast.
Okay, there it is. There we go. I think
it's big enough quite honestly. Maybe I
need to get a little bit bigger. And
I'll just scroll to the right here. But
we can see that he was indeed being
signed to Capital Records. That's where
he actually was being managed and many
of the Christian artists are. And
Capital Records, if you do not know,
it is exactly where we hear about John
Todd, a Satanist Illuminati member who
came and was managing Capital Records by
himself as a Satanist. And they would
have all of the witches and wizards and
everyone come for the master track to be
blessed, quote unquote. But the satanic
rituals would happen in the top of that
tower for Capital Records over the
master track before it was broadcasted
to all radio stations and networks. Let
that sink in. Right.
Yeah. Christians are deceived.
That is Wow. Yeah. And so when we're
listening to Christian music, there is
the same beat for one. There is the same
body language. There is the same strange
hairstyles and clothing because they're
modeling the world. They're modeling the
exact training, I'll dare say grooming
that they're being given by the
gatekeepers and all of those at Capital
Records. To even move up the food chain,
they have to do certain amounts of
meditation. They have to do certain
amounts of satanic rituals and so on to
actually get more records, more deals,
more bookings, everything. It's the
same. If they're managed by the same
people, they have to also fit the bill
and play the game just the way that
mainstream does. So, you have a lot
hiding behind those curtains. In those
closets, there are a lot of skeletons.
That's why nobody speaks out. Yeah.
And and and so where does this come
from? Because this whole pattern of
Christians that are falling and the
Christian celebrity pastors, but uh
besides that, the whole Christian music
industry, it it's its origin is going
back to Calvary Chapel. Calvary Chapel
um is uh they they basically were the
Jesus movement or the Jesus people,
right? uh the Jesus revolution the movie
uh with Jonathan Roomie uh and he also
had the Jesus music where all the gospel
artists were were connected and and and
they say that's where it all started
was there too. Um, now
the it all started with a guy called
Lonnie Frisbee, the movie, you know,
Jesus Revolution was and and they
praised the guy. They they they
highlighted all the good stuff that uh
that happened right in in that movie.
Yeah. Um but at the end of the day,
he wasn't a Christian. He was a hippie
and he became a Christian
and he still had his homosexual uh
parties and and things while he was a
Christian and leading the revival. Yeah.
Bringing in the hippie music, the music
from from from that era from that from
that day he brought in into the church
and he also was was doing drugs. Mhm.
You see the same pattern now with with
Tate, right? So the same pattern of the
and they all go back and they they they
they praise that era. That's where it
started. That's the founding of the CCM.
Well, the fruit is the same. Yeah. So
that's Christian, contemporary Christian
music. Just so anyone is not familiar
with that, it's defined clarified for
you. But yes, you're right. It's
completely the same. They all do go back
to the same origin, the same founding
fathers that they're praising,
everything. And that's where I want to
go back to these awards that Christian
artists go, you know, try to apply for
and win. How is this connected in that
same way to the same mainstream
award system perhaps? I don't know if
that's a thing, but do you know about
that at all?
Not that I'm aware of. No. But but it's
just it's just mimicking like instead of
a you know a Grammy award you get a dove
or whatever. It's I mean
as I mean there might be a connection.
Uh it doesn't surprise me. Uh you know
so yeah it's all about airplay. It's all
about um how how many times how many
records they they
sold because all you know what happens
as well is that the record uh just buys
a lot of albums back and uh and then
you're number one. It's the same with
books. They manufacture
uh you know the ones that they groomed
they get to the top and the others have
no chance. That's right. That's right.
And so I works in the same way. Yes, it
does work the same way. And that's what
I was going to point out. And I like
that you answered the question about the
award system because it's it's the same
tainted
um
misnamed system that they've given a new
name to the Dove Awards for Christians.
The same idols. So you're making we make
idols out of these mainstream artists
and even celebrities and actresses.
They've got their award system, but then
we have our Christian one that's kind of
it's the same. It's like just the same
completely, but we've given a different
name and we have different artists, but
they all have to play the same games
behind the scenes, communicating with
Satan, doing necromancy, seances.
Unfortunately, the sexual stuff comes
into play as well that you cannot do
that. Satanism,
he doesn't care how he gets you, but it
usually does include sexual rituals also
and the drugs and all of it starts to
come in. But as long as he can get you
to fall for one area where you are
under his control, he has he's got you.
And they like that. Even the uh the
gatekeepers will be like at least they
have drugs or at least they have
alcohol. Like at least they have some
way to control you also when they give
you more of that thing then you will
perform correctly.
It's a lot. Yeah. for money uh you know
of course and and well the money is the
result of course they they they get
buttloads of money um because of that
right so uh the more the more you get
higher up in the system uh and and you
know people like uh
Michael W Smith and and you know Michael
W Smith okay we'll see what comes we
we'll see what comes out right uh I
don't know uh I know that he's N for
sure. He's even reading from the Passion
translation and endorsing it. He has his
own version. And Natalie Grant, same
way. She has the ver uh she sells the
passion translation with her own cover
uh on it. Uh
so so there's there's a lot of overlap
there with new apostolic reformation but
also like uh things come out like need
to breathe uh came out later after that
uh that two brothers uh and one abused
the other brother. Um
yeah that's that's came after Tate fell
kind of like a fell flat because Tate is
of course bigger. Yeah. Um, but that's
uh another one.
Yeah. But but then you have like uh do
you call it Kman's call or something
like that? Um Cadman's Call. Yeah. Or
something. Uh yeah, that guy Derek Webb.
Uh he recently, a year or two ago, he
went with the gay Christian artist
Similar uh and another drag queen and
and he dressed up as well as a drag
queen and they went to the Dove Awards
together.
And it's all okay. Yeah. So, in my own
world, and Mikey and I were talking
about this,
um, I saw Toby Mack because I I tried to
be like, "Oh, Christian rap music."
Like, it's no like I want to have
Christian rap music and hip-hop music,
then I'll be holy. Cuz I knew the other
stuff wasn't good. Let's just say that
Toby Mack eventually I found out how
many different symbols he had on his um
CD covers and on his hands.
That's right. And talking about the
Illuminati and 666 or triangles or
pyramids and all this stuff. It turns
out he's all into it as well. And I
didn't know, but I thought why would
someone put all that stuff on there
unless they were actually signaling that
they were part of it. Turns out my
instincts were right when I was a kid.
And then we look at like Lauren Dagel,
who is new, pretty new in the world, but
she's risen to fame and she is backing
LGBTQ
plus whatever they have today. And she's
in there with them just kind of like we
are one. We are family. Everything.
She can't she can't she cannot find a
text in the Bible where where it says
that it's wrong. I'm like you never read
your Bible. Yeah. Sorry, but it's very
clear. Yeah. Yeah. So, and then John
Foreman John Foreman from uh Switchfoot.
Yeah. He uh he he fully he fully
embraced uh Semler as a gay artist and
uh you know those kind of things. I'm
like why what?
They're all doing it. uh there the rent
collective same thing also embracing the
whole thing uh and and the they're now
with Tate the whole situation with Tate
uh you hear people like well that that's
because of um the Christianity is
oppressing
uh people that are gay so they have to
leave them alone and and and let them
let them be right uh so you blur the
lines more that's that's the reaction
that's going happen, right? I've heard
that so much. Yeah. Be accepting. Be
open to it. That's why they're leaving.
That's why it's finally coming out cuz
they were oppressed. They weren't able
to live the way they wanted to. And
you're like, that's never a good reason.
It's like saying once a murderer comes
out and says they've murdered 500 people
and I just think this way, be accepting
of me. If as long as you know that
they're this way, you should be
accepting and maybe they won't kill so
many people. And that is an extreme
example. I get it. But it's the same
kind of thing. We can't be there is in
no way, and I hate to say this, but it's
so true. There actually is no acceptance
of sin for a Christian. God doesn't
accept it. And for people who really
want to stick to their sinful passions
like that,
as a Christian, you
cannot accept it either.
And so so one other thing
in in and that's what what was
mindboggling to me. I was driving in
Nashville for some for for I don't know
why uh what the reason was was a year or
two years ago. Um and I never I never
I'd never paid attention un until I was
diving into the Freemasonry stuff. But
uh Nashville is a hub a massive
Freemason hub. They have a massive grand
lodge on Broadway
very close to the SBC church where a lot
of pastors are Freemasons too. Uh mind
you uh also headquartered in Nashville.
Uh and Nashville has the Christian music
industry. Coincidence?
No. You tell you tell me.
Yeah. Um and then and then you have your
Catholic influence, right? You've got
your Jonathan Roomies, but in the music
industry, you got um two big ones. Uh
Assad,
I forgot her first name. Uh and then uh
the big one is um Matt Mayer. He's a
practicing Catholic.
He went uh to the Pope. He played for
the pope for Pope Francis back then. Um
he
he is praising the Eucharist. He's
praising the he's Catholic and he might
be a Jesuit.
What surprised me, but he is
collaborating with all the Christian
music in music people. Everyone is
writing with him with with Matt Rman
with Chris Tomlin with David Crowder. Uh
even the the casting crowns all of them.
So the walls are crumbling down. Yes.
Between Catholicism and and
Protestantism
as it should because it is a facade and
it is the false religion and false
facads now falling and we can see the
truth of it. And as speaking for myself,
I mean, I went to a few concerts when I
was a child, but ironically,
um, I got to meet a few of these
artists, and don't we all? some of us
actually get to. But um it was so
strange to see how
how emotionless,
apathetic really that they were when
they talked to you and it was just a
little bit of a chitchat or whatever,
but then you get a picture with them and
I was always like something about this
isn't right. I always felt like
something was so wrong. And you know, I
had family members and friends who'd be
like, "Well, how would you feel after a
hard day of being on on the platform and
singing and just performing? Like, it's
a hard day. What do you expect from
them?" And I said, "I expect the light
of God to still shine through them even
though they're tired, but they didn't
have any of that in my opinion." And
that kept um ringing in my my my head
and I packed it away for many years. And
um we went to someone's house that my
mom graduated high school with and he
was also some kind of manager or booking
agent or something in Colorado.
and he knew Franchesca Batistelli
um
just the artists then during that time
which were coming up and it was
Switchfoot you had casting crowns um
10th Avenue
I think is one of them and
Oh yeah
North okay and so if um that's a ways
back so I'm glad I could come up with
some names But he said they're very um
he was very honest and I I appreciate
that because he's like they're so
unhappy. They're depressed.
They are demanding and if you don't get
like their food or water for them right
away, they will cuss you out. They will
be directly just manipulative and
abusive to you.
Yeah. And did you experience that? I
heard I heard Michael W. Schmidt even
that was the same way. Yeah. Um many
artists. Um I always used to say I was
not a tour manager. I was a babysitter.
Yeah, that's what he said. He said, "I'm
one of the biggest babysitters for the
Christian world." And I was like, I was
a teenager hearing all of this. And
yeah, I just thought really because my
brother was way big into music and I
we'd always been a a musical family who
sung up in church and I just thought,
wow,
I thought something was wrong about
these people's behavior when I met them.
Um, and I could, you know, people could
say I'm stretching that and it's
something, but for me it was an instinct
that I know now is true. Like I was
actually reading it correctly.
And it's the same way when you watch,
and I'll just speak from experience,
when I've watched the video on Katie
Perry and how she rose to fame and she
started crying backstage right before
she had to go on and put her wig on and
all this stuff and then go through
counseling later, like by the time she
actually made it on stage, she gathered
herself, but she was balling. She was
straight up balling and everything
before. And then she went on, she did
her show and she was the same lack of
emotion and everything that I saw in the
artists that were Christian. And a lot
of them did, they would grab bottles
backstage right after they would come
off of the stage. And I always wondered
to myself, how many of those are
actually alcoholic drinks? Because their
attitude sure seemed like it was. And uh
it was not water that they were downing.
And um any which way again that was me
speculating and and they're the more
tipsy they got and everything. You could
see like people aren't stupid. You can
see their demeanor change. You can see
that they're becoming intoxicated
and less um aware of what they are
doing. And so
there you go. It really did ring true
for me.
I don't know what else. Yeah. Well,
there was well there was a um I believe
uh was with Gavin Max back back in the
day. Um and uh there was a Christian
festival in the Netherlands and he was
performing and he was uh he was he had
joined behind his uh he had a joint
already downed and he had already half a
bottle of wine downed. Uh so before he
went on stage and then he was like I
want to be in the light right that song
and all kinds of other songs but then uh
a guy from my old church came to me and
he was like
something's off. Yeah. I just I just
wanted to tell you I don't understand
what's what's going on but yeah it
doesn't seem right. And I told him the
truth. I'm like yeah you're you're
seeing it exactly right. Yeah it is off.
So there are not a lot of people that
see that.
They just are delusion
delusion.
How do you say it? Uh uh deceived and
and they just just don't want to see it.
Um or can see it. Um
I don't know.
No, I know people who
to who flock flock to the concerts and
buy up all the tickets that they can for
like their family and their friends and
everything still. And I can't say that I
have ever gone to one again since I
realized a lot of this. I've um
admittedly I've never
I should take that back. It's not never,
but I have only been to a few concerts
in my life that were at all Christian or
mainstream, but very
many of them, like four of them that I
can remember in my lifetime were
Christian. And I just never did go back.
It was a waste of time for me to see
them put on a false
show of what a Christian is supposed to
live like on stage. Even though they had
great voices, don't get me wrong. I know
lots of musicians, even ones that are in
the professional
world and they're learning a lot of how
to play games. They're all faking that
they're good and they know how to sing
good no matter what, but their attitude
just is terrible and they learn to lie
about all of it all the time. And um
Well, you have to the the higher up you
get you get the more you have to do it.
Yeah. Yeah. So, it's this dual
personality thing, and I I only know
that because that's a part of Satanism
as well. For you to split personalities
and actually have to take on two at once
or multiple even. Um, that's mental a
mental health disorder that they want
you to take on in the satanic occult
worlds. So, they're doing that very well
even in the quote unquote contemporary
Christian world.
Um,
so I don't really have anything to add
to this, but I'm Thank you for coming on
if you want to add anything to it. But
we need to be discerning and I'm really
glad it's coming out because like I
said, it's not the first time. I hope
we're waking up finally to it though
because of what's happening, what just
came out about Michael Tate. But I don't
know how we never thought that the
Christian world was not exactly the
same. We're all humans. We're all
sinners. You cannot look at each other.
Stop.
Stop. And don't support it anymore.
Please.
Keep your eyes on on Jesus. That's
that's all I can say. I mean, uh I mean
I've seen it as well like with pastors,
with of course with artists as well. I I
was young, right?
in my in my 18 years and even before
that
I looked up to to these people because I
was a fan of those those artists uh in
the past. So you've been looking up to
artists and and and
they fail you. They always will fail you
as you I said earlier on they always
will fail you. So at the end of the day
it's not worth it. And the Bible is very
clear. Don't build, you know, don't
build of uh don't uh put your trust in
man. Uh put your trust in Christ. That
is the most important thing. And if you
don't, if you if you keep building on on
on sinking sand, it's it's you're gonna
fall down again and again and again.
Amen. Very true.
Can say. But yeah, I I've been in in in
in everybody's shoes. I've I for and I
fought my parents even because they were
like why why don't you get out of it
right and I was like no I love music and
uh this is my passion and uh so I know
exactly I know how addictive it is it is
addiction yes it is an addiction
and you want more yeah so um on that
note when I was recovering and I I mean
that I mean I actually had to go through
withdrawal just like a drug addict did
because I was I had the shakes and
everything when I went through
withdrawal from music. When you actually
allow it to overtake your body like
that, your body is going to have
repercussions from being used. And so I
I shook violently and had to just
hold on to the chair I was sitting in or
whatever and just hold on and and be
with God in my mind and in my heart and
just he gave me verses. He was there
with me. That's the only way I got
through it. But it was um you know just
like any other recovering addict. It was
months of that. And so
and for for me it's different for me I I
wasn't involved in that way
[Music]
but
Oops. For me it was more
you hear me again? One second. It needs
to clear up just a second here.
Okay. Try it now. Yeah.
Okay. So, so it was different for me,
but uh for so for me because I wasn't
performing. Uh for me it was like I
needed to I I stepped away from
everything music. I I I
didn't want to I didn't go to concerts
and still I have a hard time listening
to to Christian music or music at all.
That is uh and I love music. I loved
music, right? So, it's hard, but at the
same time, I I I learned how to deal
with it. How to just silence because
we're That's another thing that I want
to add to this conversation. We're We're
so used now to noise all the time. Music
everywhere, in the store, in the car,
everywhere. There's no silence. Yeah.
We're afraid of silence. And and I think
it's good to step back and and and and
be in the silence. just be, you know,
nothing. But people are afraid of that.
Yes. So that's what I realized when I
was using it. It was when I was sad,
when I was alone to to escape the
silence, everything. But I realized
while I was reading the Bible during
these withdrawals, it says God will
speak to you in the silence. So we
shouldn't be afraid of facing oursel in
the silence. We need to get used to the
silence in some ways to hear his small
voice. And so I don't know, it's just
amazing. And I had to step away from all
music, too. Just I even Mikey, I'll tell
you, he'll be like, "Do you want to
listen to something?" No. In the car.
Uh-uh. Like I usually just turn
everything off and it's driving with
sounds of nature in the car and just
talking. If if anything at all, it's
either just silence or talking. And um
my siblings still to this day. Huh?
Still to this day. Still to this day.
Yeah. No, I can't I can't do it very
well. I I
I've tried I've tried turning on some
things and being with other people who
have Christian music on and um usually
my siblings and they don't always know
where I'm coming from. H yeah, I cringe.
I always cringe when I hear
Yeah. I I just
seriously like there we go again. Yeah.
Sometimes you can't if you can't help
it, you cannot turn it off. Right. So,
Exactly. And then I'm like, "Please
Lord, help me through this." It's
cringing. Exactly. I have to pray a lot
and I have to keep a mental control of
my spiritual world in my head because
it's like, "Do not do not do not." And
it's it's actually getting to you or
it's driving you nuts that the person
has music on. But you're right, you
can't always turn it off to be
respectful. But at one point or another,
my siblings are kind of like,
you know, what would you like to listen
to or or do you want music on at all?
And I finally just So I told them, "No,
I I'd rather just have the silence." And
they usually they're they're good. They
just respect that and turn it off and
I'm finally okay. Um but I do want to to
emphasize here Mikey wrote because he's
in the chat. He said, "Be still and know
that I am God." That is so true. How
many of us are taking time to be still,
to know God at all? Like, you're right.
We are seriously bombarding our hearts
and our head with confusion and noise
all the time. And God can't work through
that. You are actually the one
confusion. Exactly. Yes. And theological
confusion. Yes, that is correct. And if
you are saying, "Oh, I can't hear God.
He doesn't talk to me." All this stuff.
How much of the time are you plugged
into something like a TV? First of all,
I know that's not literally plugging
yourself in, but technology overwrites
emotions a lot of the time. So, TV, your
iPad, your phone, uh, iTunes, Twitter,
any of these things where you're
listening to music or you're watching
something, you're being plugged into.
It's like a manipulation tool. Just
I don't know what it what is it called?
Uh, brainwashing. like just you're being
programmed.
And so be careful what you're
programming your brain with. That's why
you're probably maybe here listening to
this cuz some people want to know how to
program your brain for Christ instead of
programming it for mainstream uh
ecumenical or satanic agendas here.
And that's good. I really hope that
everyone thinks about that.
And it's hard as a young person. I I
still consider myself a young person.
Most people around me are not
befriendable because they're so on their
phones with their music going constantly
and their earphones or earbuds in all
the time. This is the only time you'll
see me wearing usually any earbuds is on
the show. Otherwise, I don't have things
in my ears.
I'm plugged into the world around me
where God speaks to me and uses the
world when I'm cleaning, when I'm
gardening, when I'm doing this stuff.
I'm present with people. You have to be
present with people to be fully used by
God and impressionable by him.
Otherwise, you got other forces within
you that are messing with that ability.
Actually, that's the best way I can put
it. Yeah.
Yeah. Absolutely.
Absolutely. Um and and and that and that
that's another thing. We've been made so
um
self everything is is towards self. It's
not only the preaching, but it's also
with your what you're saying with your
ears ears in is like don't talk to me.
Yeah. Um you're right. Yeah. We're we're
made we're made lonely. Yes. And it's
our own doing. If we were just
we're not made for being lonely. Yeah.
We're made for for community, right? So,
yeah, very true. All right, we've
covered so many things, but I'm really
glad. I did not know we would have so
much to say from our our different
backgrounds, but have that same um
understanding of music and so much to
say on it. Thank you for being here,
Menow. And thank you everyone for tuning
in. Yes, it's a pleasure to always have
you. You always bring so much
information that is mind-blowing. It's
it's incredible. We'll be we'll be back
with with our episodes. Yeah, we will.
We will.
All right, everyone.
Yes. Yes, definitely. I'm going to go
through and show if you want to support
our channel. We know that you love what
we bring. So, we want to bring you more.
Please go ahead and visit these links.
We have Candid Truce Cash App. We have
Venmo. We have Zel and PayPal right now.
We also have and I'm sorry I don't have
a picture of that but we also have a
fundraiser going on on our website. Go
to canidtruth.org
for the book. We got more Aby's strange
dreams book about teaching people their
children mainly children's book about
spiritual war warfare to teach your kids
how to use the sword of the spirit and
the armor of God to fight off Satan when
he comes for your children. So they will
know how to discern truth from error.
And if you want to give to that, we did
go ahead and we ordered in faith.
Especially Mikey, he took that. He's all
about the kids on our channel. And he
went and ordered
2,000 more copies on our credit card,
which was a $5,000 bill that we now need
your help to cover.
If you, like I said, want to give to
this, please go ahead and get on the
channel or on our website and go ahead
and donate to that. Please uncheck
though the tip box. They will have a
option for you to give a tip. That means
they take a portion of it. Please
uncheck that before you give and that
will go 100% to us then. And so, thank
you for being here. We do have
merchandise as you know also on our
channel. Go to merch or shop even. It
should be all there. And I hope you guys
all have a blessed evening. We are very
happy to have you. We've been talking
about a lot. Um
and I just I hope that you like our
candidness. That's why we did this.
That's why we founded this channel. We
talk about a lot of these topics
because we have a lot of things of this
world and our media and society to
expose to showcase and we're going to be
talking candid about it. So, thank you
all for tuning in. Have a good evening
and we will see you next time. All
right. Bye-bye.